[Música]
[Aplausos]
lá o nome de dores
já tivemos aqui várias toca à fala de
tecnologia e eu vou começar por eles de
anos na frança há 200 anos presa foi o
historial
até que um dia tem sobre uma forma
extraordinária a chegar nos pontos onde
estamos até com digital com esse
desenvolvimento da tecnologia eles
aumentar o nosso nível de vida da nossa
riqueza do nosso estado nossa saúde
qualquer indicador que vocês vejam
mortalidade infantil de educação de de
produto interno bruto demonstra que o
mundo está hoje muito melhor do que
estava há 200 anos atrás
isso não vai parar aqui até que um dia
está a chorar com essa transmissão
digital que pode haver aqui um exemplo
na energia o a história hoje 84 por
cento mais barata de produzir do que há
dez anos atrás
a energia eólica é 50% mais barato
produzido que há dez anos atrás
é muito possível daqui é muito poucos
anos
com estas e nos dias que são renováveis
sejam também as linhas mais baratas e
que o nosso problema deles dias
resolvido na computação
a google tem hoje está o primeiro
computador quântico é um computador tem
uma velocidade de computação que 100
milhões de vezes superior aos
computadores com sistema em casa
cem milhões de vezes superior faça
ensina precisam de ensino à distância
está assim a era espacial vamos daqui a
pouco tempo para mineração é migrar as
tropas para trazer recursos para a terra
é muito possível
aqui neste século nós finalmente
chegamos onde chegamos à sociedade a
abundância
a sociedade não quer era uma das nossas
necessidades daquelas que andamos há 70
mil anos com seres humanos há 10 mil
anos de civilização é bem possível a
todas as nossas necessidades mais
importantes estejam de uma
por todas as dúvidas
como é que vamos funcionar como
sociedade seria extraordinário
difícil imaginar um plano a um pandeiro
então estude está a correr tão bem por
que tantas más notícias que os
indicadores demonstram que estamos a
viver melhor na tabela enfatizou
diminuir a pobreza no mundo a diminuir
porque hoje tivemos aqui várias tops e
basta chegar em casa e ligar a televisão
e vão ver isso
medo medo do nosso futuro
medo dentro da nossa privacidade medo da
manipulação da democracia e que vemos a
cada toque exatamente sobre o medo
porque essas empresas são demasiado
poderosas medo porque não confiamos na
nossa informação medo porque vamos todos
para redes sociais que resultaram nos
outros dias regras do do corpo da
parceira um medo porque os empregos da
manhã vão desaparecer por causa da
questão digital
o estudo foi por exemplo portugal
mostrava que a perda bruta de empregos
pode ser de cerca de 1 milhão de
empregos até 2030 é é a de tecnologia -
traseira sociedade a abundância estamos
todos com medo da forma como a nossa
sociedade vai confinar para gerir esse
bem estar
vivemos factos numa enorme frustração da
nossa existência
por um lado e por outro lado a nossa
sociedade é forma de estarmos uns com os
outros parece não conseguir avançar e
desenvolver o mesmo a velocidade com que
a tecnologia envolve podemos ter duas
funções
eu acho que é o que fazemos sempre pensa
na área
nos anos em que aqui que enquanto aqui
estamos depois
alguém a desenvolver esse problema não
pode ser assim
a história demonstra nos claramente
nestas alturas da humanidade não haver
soluções para os problemas começaram
este ciclo do medo leva nos longas que
ir ao sectarismo que gera mais medo e
mais sectarismo e o ciclo medo leva
sempre a destruição leva sempre a
violência leva sempre a guerra
nesta bifurcação estamos hoje a nossa
história ou como humanidade encontra-se
uma nova forma de estar como em vidros
com instituições com empresas como em
dias com fundações com sociedade novas
regras estavam uns com os outros porque
tecnologia traga riqueza e bem-estar
funções com as quais possamos todos
conviver e partilhar a sociedade a
abundância e também a sociedade a
felicidade e solucionado bem estar e à
sociedade as relações entre gestores ou
criamos esta nova trazendo de volta à
sociedade a confiança ea frança nesta
nova tecnologia ou então estamos a
entrar pelos caminhos mais negro da
nossa história comum como é que vamos
conseguir entrar neste caminho em que
bens tecnologia e capacidade de produzir
resolução dos problemas significa também
uma tirada mais coisa uma cidade com
mais pressa uma sociedade com mais
confiança das pessoas e urgência é
enorme
como vimos aqui já em número de toques
antes desta
as coisas estão a passar hoje depressa e
precisam de ação
a solução dos problemas da nossa
sociedade passa como desmatem outra quem
não por todas as pessoas mas por um
grupo concretos hoje vou citar martin
luther king
o progresso humano não é nem automático
nem inevitável queda passo no sentido de
justiça requer sacrifício requer
sofrimento quer luta e paixão de cada de
um certo grupo de indivíduos são esses
indivíduos que trazem a sociedade
no caminho o herói eu queria lembrar
aqui que antes de mim um deus não chegam
o problema é muito maior do que alguns
heróis que é bom vocês quando uma pessoa
está nesta platéia tela própria
transformar no herói e não vamos perder
mas é fundamental não podemos cada um
dos talentos que existem no mundo capaz
de ser herói capaz de trazer soluções
novas para novos problemas que já presta
na nossa sociedade
o sítio e agora é importante para mim
o sítio onde o potencial de cada uma das
pessoas que têm a capacidade de ser um
herói realizar em movimento no sistema
educativo com paixão da minha vida
o sistema educativo que tem
fundamentalmente transformar deixar de
ser um sítio onde se aprende uma série
de competências técnicas foi costume
reproduzida a seguir ao longo da vida
somos capazes de inspirar os heróis os
heróis que vão trazer novas funções
prazo expirado
hoje temos que encontrar esses heróis em
seus propósitos
este é o montado criar impacto esse é o
de empatia gostoso idade do poder para
criar essa mudança
mais uma vez o herói paz ampla só passam
pelas tops do teto continuamente mas eu
tenho certeza que há muitos muitos mais
por esse mundo fora por esse país fora
por haver fora cujo potencial tem que
ter trazido o nosso sistema de ensino
que hoje francamente não fazem é preciso
transformar o sistema de ensino é
preciso criar nos termos de ensino é
capacidade para fazer exatamente esta
expo shares descobrir do herói daqueles
que querem ser e eu queria contribuir
trazemos aqui é que estão o sim é poder
eu acho que esses novos heróis que o 21o
sim superpoderes não tem a ver com as
aranhas do homem aranha não tem a ver
com voar como um super homem mas muito
próximo de nós nos podem inspirar e
podem inspirar novas universidades é
fazer descobrir aos nossos alunos que
faziam descobrir as duas partes
trabalham conosco
o primeiro dos superpoderes
é um meu lado a humildade é importante e
fundamental no futuro nós vamos estar
numa sociedade que é tão complexa com
problemas ainda mais complexo e chaves
de simples e questões simples como vai
parar a imigração
vamos construir uma barreira vão
resolver o problema estamos
fundamentalmente erradas
o problema do nacionalismo e do
populismo e é exatamente essa é chata
problemas tão complexos como o que
vivemos hoje resolvidos com soluções
simples os heróis da esperança tem que
reconhecer a dificuldade dos problemas
tem que conhecer como está em
simplificar para explicar não é
simplismo e tem que segurar uma
capacidade de lidar com essa
complexidade herói bem disse uma vez
quando estava a transformar a china é o
princípio dos anos 80
não me interessa se um gato é preto
branco ou vermelho deste cassados e esse
pragmatismo é fundamental nos dias de
hoje
nós hoje temos preço do ontem
temos ideologias do príncipe
o século 20 foi feita para resolver
problemas que começaram no fim do século
estamos a tentar resolver problemas do
século 21 com os mesmos 21 dias
estamos na direita e na esquerda em 10
foram criadas literalmente do princípio
do século 20
e é com essas idéias queremos resolver
os problemas de hoje não vai funcionar
nunca vai ganhar uma emprego matismo uma
abertura para que as idéias não sejam
julgadas previamente com base nas
tecnologias em que estamos mas sejam
julgados com base em resultados confessa
o 40 year of ascent of jobs que
organizou sempre essa criatividade
achava esta vontade de nunca se criar
uns perguntam aos consumidores nunca
criar na margem mas fazer algo radical e
fundamentalmente novo
há que pensar fora da caixa a cantar
dentro da caixa
francamente a partir da caixa toda e
começar uma caixa toda a nova exigência
nós temos a primeira resposta qualquer
ele vai ser sempre não é a segunda
resposta a quem vai ser sempre não é a
primeira vez que tentava fazer alguma
coisa de sempre falhar a segunda vez
tentava alguma coisa sempre foi a e
acerto
este falhanço esta gestão vamos fazer
das nossas idéias ainda mais forte
não há resultado ser violência inspirada
neste caso foi uma surpresa
o último princípio talvez mais
importantes como o superpoder dos nossos
numerosos praça é da coragem
a idéia de que está sozinha defender uma
idéia está sozinho contra todos não é
necessariamente o errado é coragem para
pôr publicamente não ter medo do
ridículo ou não ter medo isto porque
aquilo que acreditamos é
fundamentalmente são então este o chico
superpoder eu acho que as escolas hoje
tem que dar para libertarem as dívidas
de longo prazo e se eu pudesse escolher
um grande inspirador
as universidades ou amanhã seria a
escola professor chaves de ver de onde
saem os x men
nestes casos é filme
porque de facto mais importante do que
em primeiro aquelas coisas que os ensina
é importante queda uma das pessoas que
cada um de vocês dos nossos filhos e os
nossos netos passa por uma escola por
município dada uma escola encontra forma
de desenvolver a sua empatia o seu
sentido popov o seu sentido querer fazer
a diferença e com humildade a está em
com o pragmatismo delben
com criatividade arrojada steve jobs
aliança chamada teresa e coragem numa
tenda tem consigam criar uma tribo
heróis que consiga salvar a sociedade de
si própria e consiga acabar com o ciclo
medo e consiga fundamentalmente trazer
volta como retirado ea esperança e de
confiança em toda a riqueza tecnologia é
vivida no edital não goste muito
obrigado meu boneco
[Aplausos]